right now the Dances with Wolves actor
is in jail we do have team coverage for
you tonight of this high profile case
Victoria Saha is live outside his North
Las Vegas home talking to neighbors
first though eight news now investigator
Vanessa Murphy is uncovering new details
in the investigation
Nathan chasing horses accused of acting
as a type of medicine man and spiritual
leader to then victimize indigenous
young girls for at least two decades the
question how did this go on for so long
this is a very serious serious situation
as the events and the information starts
rolling no actor Nathan chasing horse
now the center of an international
investigation police say he led a cult
known as the circle told underage girls
Spirits wanted them to have sex with him
and physically and sexually abused women
and children repeatedly police say he
targeted indigenous girls in need this
is video of the SWAT team outside his
North Las Vegas home Tuesday before he
was taken into custody police say he's
believed to have as many as Six Wives
and he had a plan for the women to take
suicide pills if police showed up as
well as preparation for a shootout on
Wednesday police from two different
departments in Canada announcing they're
investigating the Dances with Wolves
actor also we could have victims across
the country here in Canada I mean we may
not be aware of Metro Police say chasing
horses believed to have recorded himself
committing sexual assaults so far
they've identified at least three
victims of sexual salt in Clark County
but believe there are many more chasing
horse traveled around the country and
Canada for Spiritual ceremonies now
Metro and other departments are asking
other potential victims to come forward
could you maybe comment on that of
perhaps how this may have gone on for so
long
it's certainly something concerning that
we are very attuned to as we reported
Tuesday night other allegations include
that Nathan chasing horse forced his
victims to take emergency contraception
to make sure they didn't get pregnant
after he sexually assaulted them